talk about Boris Johnson again in more
detail he allegedly broke covered rules
Again by inviting friends over to
Checkers his grace and favor home during
lockdown but his spokesperson says it's
nonsense and he's going to sue let's
find out should we what conservative
peer and pulse the Lord Hayward has to
say about it hi good morning to see you
um your whole take on what's Happening
it's a wild roller coaster in terms of
events and I think it's right that if
people whoever they may be have
discovered further entries in Diaries or
whatever that they have to be looked at
otherwise there's an accusation of
cover-up in some form or another and to
be honest I think Boris Johnson's aides
are probably ill-advised to kind of say
it's a stitch up and all the rest of it
just say We'll answer the cases the
issues as and when they arise
why now do you think
I actually do believe that events happen
in a series of a series of circumstances
and therefore it's come out because
somebody's been looking at Diaries in
terms of the covert inquiry as we
understand it I don't have a full
details I don't think any of us do at
this stage so I think it's unlikely to
be quote a stitch up it's just a series
of events which have to be looked at
I mean
Boris Johnson says there's no case to
answer here if he thought he was doing
anything wrong he wouldn't put it in his
diary would he probably not no he'd
certainly be unwise to do it and he if
he believes that and it's a fair
observation then why then turn around
and say it's a stitch up just say I will
answer the issues at the point when
whichever inquiry looks at the events
and the circumstances and what impact
will it have on the inquiry I'm guessing
it's all part of the inquiry that's a
decision for the members of the team to
look at decide how they handle it decide
whether it is relevant to the terms of
their inquiry my guess is that they will
and that therefore it will delay events
because Boris Johnson gave evidence if
this is new information which we
understand it to be the case from May
the 18th then he's got to have the
opportunity to answer that whether
that's in writing or in person so it
will delay the inquiry and the the
results of that even further
what impact will it have on Rishi sunak
and his attempts to study the ship I
think it's for him it must be very
frustrating in the same way that with
Sue Ella as well and bravaman as well
um he's got good news this morning in
terms of inflation he had the IMF
figures yesterday and these form a
distraction having said that uh there
are those who would like to see Boris
back as leader or Sue Ella's future
leader it makes it more difficult for
them to argue when you've got these
constant noises off stage which are
distractions and say well it's a bit
risky for the Tory party to go there in
that route and how is it how is his
Premiership doing has he managed to
study the ship
he had very disappointing local
government election results there's no
question the opinion polls have seen a
downturn in late April early May they've
now begun to recover back to what they
were but they're not where he would want
them to be their several percentage
points short and the polls show at the
moment that KIA starmer would have a
minority Administration but an election
is a year and a half off
Rishi is suffering from the distractions
of other people when he wants to get the
message across we have got the economy
under control although the figures this
morning at 8.7 show that inflation is
sticky even though it is below 10 at
last interesting you say um
an election 18 months away I said that
at lunch to someone yesterday they said
no it's much less than that no it's
October and it's to do with inflation
figures because any opinion poll shows
that cost of living the economy is the
top issue immigration NHS these sorts of
things come further down the line but
cost of living and cost of living is not
just the goods that you buy in the
supermarket but it's also the interest
rates that people pay in terms of their
mortgage and at the local elections
there's a fair amount of evidence that
actually it was the people who've just
faced interest rate increases on their
mortgage who didn't go out and vote for
the conservatives who had previously
said they would so those interest rates
have to come down that takes time it's
not going to be early it's going to be
October next year okay
um that won't be influenced by sorry
just took off that would be influenced
by the U.S elections and anything that
Trump might be up to I think that's
unlikely we've got more than enough
issues to to tackle in this country
including immigration United immigration
there we've got the figures coming out
tomorrow uh what do they need to show in
order to have a balance for the
government I I don't think they
immediately have a banks for the
government it's an issue that it matters
to a certain group of people essentially
conservative voters and it's illegal
immigration that matters most but Sue
Ella Braven as Home Secretary and the
government as a whole have to show that
they have the issue under control in
terms of legal immigration as well as
illegal immigration how popular do you
think Zoella bravaman is with the public
it looks as though on the face of it
that she's potentially broken the
ministerial code again
um again got to go down the route of of
a proper review and give everybody the
opportunity to have their say she is not
popular with a lot of people an opinion
poll show that that there are people
she's one of these people who is very
much Marmite other brands are available
but um but people have a view about her
and it's either positive or negative
very strongly one way or the other
um why is she in post then if she's not
popular that
she came back to do a certain job she's
tackling it the question is and the
immigration issue is at her door so she
has to show that she's got it in control
what would that look like tomorrow with
the figures it depends how it's made
it's only what about 40 000 people yes
that's that's a drop in the bucket it is
in terms of the other other legal
migration but the question is whether
the migrants have come from the Ukraine
whether they where they've come from
Afghanistan students those sorts of
students families which you've been
referring to already this morning and
those have got to be seen to be under
control and they are the responsibility
of essentially of the Home Secretary